VTS on a GT the kpop sensation
kicked off Wednesday's results show of
America's Got Talent
performing their latest single Idol and
they brought the crowd to their feet and
then RM was saying that he loves me from
back in the day of the Tyra show well
I'm like oh hold are you and you're
watching daytime talk show fans die hard
though they're pretty amazing
sexualisation like the Asian man that I
just feel like has gotten a bad rap in
media for so long and to have that love
and for girls to be like oh my god I
want to go bad is politically socially
spiritually Tyra Banks is a proud member
of the BTS army Heidi Klum even snuck in
a selfie with the group backstage you
got a selfie with BTS do you know if you
realize million that people would want
them what's it like being in the
presence and knowing that they're
literally being followed by thousands of
beep screaming girls I mean they're like
I think what the Backstreet Boys or the
Beatles and you know where every woman
on this planet is going absolutely
wasn't crazy every that pitch the high
pitch of this 3
is just beyond you can hardly hear the
song because the screaming of the
audience is so loud
[Applause]